il ya eu des fautes et des crimes il ya
eu des grandes choses et des histoires
heureuses mais j'ai une conviction
profonde
notre responsabilité n'est pas de nous y
enterrer notre responsabilité n'est pas
de rester dans ce passé mais de vivre l
aventure pleine et entière de cette
génération sont d'une génération de
français pour qui les crimes de la
colonisation européenne sont
incontestables et font partie de notre
histoire
je me reconnais dans les voix d'albert
londres et d'andré gide qui ont dénoncé
les milliers de morts du chemin de fer
du congo
et je n'oublie pas que ces voies alors
on était minoritaire en france comme en
europe